[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
sur tv 78 de votre émission avec de
l'actualité des loisirs pour bien
terminer la semaine dans les yvelines
voici le sommaire de ce vendredi 24
septembre
depuis son ouverture en janvier le
vaccinodromes de saint quentin en
yvelines a réalisé plus de 350000
injections contre le collier 19 une
action qui a été primé récemment par le
trophée des territoires nous en parlons
avec jean michel fourgous président de
la collectivité
architecture c'est le nom de cette
exposition légaux visible jusqu'au 2
janvier à l'espace sacha n'auriez de
croissy sur seine des constructions
entre le réel et l'imaginaire un petit
sorcier célèbre nous la fera visiter
enfin nos idées de sorties pour le
week-end avec le de la musique notamment
le festival chapiteau concert se déroule
pendant trois jours au tremblay sur
mauldre une programmation éclectique
avec notamment l'harmoniciste greg zlap
qui a collaboré pendant dix ans avec
johnny hallyday et il sera notre invité
tout à l'heure dans la partie loisirs
qui est animé par bixente mayence
insisté ban bonjour bonjour grégory
alors pas que ce festival au programme
mais aussi d'autres choses pour ce
week-end et le week-end à presse oui on
va parler des nocturnes électro à
versailles des rencontres de l'arbre ou
même d'une petite escapade orientale et
ce sera tout à l'heure dans le 7-8 week
end
mais d'abord je reçois sur ce plateau
jean michel fourgous bonjour bonjour
résidant de saint quentin en yvelines
vous êtes également le maire de la
commune d'elancourt l'agglomération
figurent parmi les lauréats des trophées
et des territoires c'est une distinction
attribuée par le groupe des lbo presse
l'agent sky à communication la chaîne le
web comme tv est aussi des experts en
compétitivité territoriale
le but c'est de distinguer les
territoires les plus actifs et les plus
représentatifs et vous avez reçu ce
trophée pour l'action sanitaire et
l'action sanitaire dans votre gestion et
de la crise qu l'idée pour ce
vaccinodromes ouvert depuis janvier au
sein du vélodrome national plus de
350000 injection qui ont été réalisés
cette distinction que vous
inspire-t-elle eh bien d'abord que il
faut agir dans la vie c'est bien de
commenter mais surtout dans une aussi
grave
crise la plus grave depuis 1945
bien sûr il faut décision rapide je
crois que c'est un des éléments qui nous
fait d'obtenir ce prix une première
décision et d'un vaccinodromes et non
pas de petits centres on a modifié
contrairement à ce que l'on demande et
donc on a tout de suite engagé sur un
actionneur rom avec des gros moyens
c'est un des gros rouleurs fallu
mobiliser c'est comme une opération qui
lui a coûté 20 millions sur l'année
2021 en valorisation de partenariat mais
il ya plein partenaires mais en gros
c'est comme un très gros bon ensuite
c'est près de 1000 personnes qui ont été
mobilisés médecins pharmaciens
infirmier
personne de sécurité administratif
pompiers policiers pendant et unique
saison très professionnelle puisque
c'est rare il y avait mille huit cent
lieux de vaccination en france avant
donc celle des premiers bons mais je
dirais
très grosse médiatisation aussi official
kia qui a augmenté
l'envi de se faire vacciner donc
et comme on accélérait les vaccinations
en même temps on augmente l envie il a
été calculé par des médecins qu'on
n'avait sauvé 600 personnes de la mort
sur 330 mille aujourd'hui
350 milles injections réalisées c'est à
peu près 41 % de ce qui s'est fait dans
les yvelines si on prend la globalité
dans les yvelines du coup c'est une
fierté de pouvoir aujourd'hui présenté
ce bilan oui mais c'est aussi parce que
parce qu'on a de belles entreprises il
faut le dire donc on a des moyens bien
sûr on a des partenaires puissants faut
le dire région département et a aussi
qu'elle jouait le jeu vous le dirait ce
bon et puis je dirais
12 le 12 12 communes enfin bon trappe
c'est un peu compliqué vingt douze
communes vraiment qu'ils ont qui ont
fait corps dans ce projet pour le rendre
puissant efficace les ccas de chaque
commune qui ont préparé vraiment les
gens donc pour que ça accélère soit bien
bien bien professionnel qu'on les fasse
attendre le minimum avec une
administration très importante qui
allait j'ai bien sûr qui a fait gagner
un temps considérable tout un système
numérique on est même fait venir dix ému
avec très élaborés pour aller encore
plus vite bon voila mais en tout cas ça
montre que saint quentin c'est réagir
très vite efficacement et de façon
solidaire c'est aussi un des éléments
dans le prix c'est qu'ils savent que
nous avons partagé
les vaccinations on a vacciné aussi des
beaucoup de communes accès plus de 100
communes autour de saint quentin parce
que des kits commune ce cas pas les
mêmes moyens donc voyez dans une crise
comme ça les uns étaient 50% parce que
souvent disait oui saint-quentin ils ont
les moyens et caetera et depuis que les
médecins lui
beaucoup de choses non mais non
on était branché après sur le plan
national de toute façon et on aider tout
le monde même elle est l'objectif
annoncé quoi cette visée les 500 milles
alors bien entendu on peut atteindre 500
milles mais aussi les enfants viennent
se faire vacciner bon pour l'instant
c'est quand même là on en a vacciné
contre 110 % mans mais s'est dit alors
est-ce qu'on passe demain la barre en
dessous de 12 ans je peux pas vous le
dire est ce que la troisième vaccination
on a percuté avec ce n'est plus de 2000
personnes en troisième vaccination pour
les seniors qui a déboursé partie mais
ça dépendra du nom on peut être un
effectivement ni millions comme vous le
dites je peux pas vous le garantir ça
dépendra mais nous on sait on sait
aujourd'hui on maîtrise on a appris mais
on a 50 ans maîtrise d'un savoir faire
en tout cas aujourd'hui pour vacciner
cent mille personnes en cas d'urgence
par mois donc dans les meilleures
conditions puisque l'on n'a eu aucun
accident significatif et il vous dira
que alors on a on a découvert on s'est
créé une nouvelle compétence je voulais
pas que c'est pas une compétence qui
emmenait une agglo
et puis je dirais je dirais que
on avait bien sûr al'avantage d'avoir de
savoir gérer des événements
internationaux faut quand même le dire
aussi il fait d'avoir quatre sites
olympiques on a en un savoir-faire nos
équipes à savoir faire mais sur
combinaison gros événement où il avait
vu clair avec la ryder cup vous devrez
aller aux olympiques ivoiriens sur mais
bon en vrai tout ça
toute cette somme a fait mais je veux
dire qu'on doit ce succès à toulouse a
beaucoup de gens mais en tout cas il n
ya au moins quelque chose on peut que
quelqu'un qui était forcé de rassembler
tout ça de faire entrer des gens très
différents par exemple m les messins
vont nous aider trail des gens des
hôpitaux et du monde privé ces deux
mondes différents on l'a compris et sur
une dernière question jusqu'à quand ça
va fonctionner ce maxi d'euros de tss
vaccinodromes en format donc
vaccinodromes au vélodrome écoutez moi
je suivrai là dessus l'énorme un peu
c'est quand même l'état je sais si je
critique les thèmes et qu'elle était qui
et qui sait exactement dans les
prévisions la donc si nous demande
jusqu'au 31 12 ans restera de ce contrat
mais aussi au 30 octobre bien sûr on
peut fermer parce que faut que ce soit
rentable et nous on est un gros sens
donc vaut mieux passer la main sur un
petit sentier des doses si un
affaiblissement plutôt que de garder un
gros centre comme acquis et fait surtout
pour les situations d'urgence massive
c'est ce qui à ses skieurs étaient
prouvées donc je dirai ce sera entre fin
octobre et fin et fin décembre mais je
dirais là dessus je je je travaillais
que gouvernement je ne vais pas prendre
une initiative personnelle vu le nombre
de gens qui sont concernés est ce que
les enfants demain est-ce que les
seigneurs est ce que il ya un nouveau
variant qui va arriver voilà donc ces
variables je souhaite conserver les gros
ils vont fermer les petits ils veulent
garder un gros par département bon alors
oui bonjour on discute mais on ne nous
on est là pour protéger notre population
on l'a fait et on est on est prêt à
aller tendre le temps
nécessaire mais adapté un accident dont
vous raconte nous maintiennent pour 500
vaccinations par jour et on n'est pas
adapté donc voilà on s'adapte en tout
cas on a trois vitesses on l'a montré
on est prêt à passer la petite vitesse
ou bien effectivement j'irai sortir puis
passer la main lors il ya le problème
des monodoses les médecins le disent
nous on veut bien maxine et se forme
hausse mais à condition que vous ne
donniez des monodoses ce qu'ils peuvent
pas prendre ouvrir un truc pour cette
dose et puis vacciner qu'une seule
personne c'est moi vous avez une perte
qui paient aucune aucun équilibre qui ce
fait reste avec nous jean michel
fourgous petite pause dans cet entretien
pour revenir sur l'actualité de la
semaine yvelinoise s est résumée par
mélanie poker est la voix de nicolas
landry
après la rentrée les évaluations depuis
cinq ans septembre les élèves de cp
bûche en français et en mathématiques
18000 yvelinois les ont passées jusqu'au
23 septembre dayraut à quatre pattes
cinq chiens des pompiers des yvelines
ont été récompensé d'un trophée ils sont
capables de détecter des maladies comme
le co lead les technologies du numérique
se met au service des collectivités
territoriales une matinée de conférences
s'est tenue autour de la thématique
bâtir des territoires de confiance au
théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines trois thématiques pour la
protection économique des entreprises la
gendarmerie des yvelines le medef et la
cgpme organisé cette semaine des
ateliers auprès d'une cinquantaine de
chefs d'entreprise les incendiaires du
chapiteau de chanteloup les vignes sont
devant la justice depuis le 22 septembre
une audience quasiment deux ans après
les faits le lieu culturel s'est
embrasée lors de scènes de violences
urbaines 26 septembre ce sont les
virades de l'espoir un événement profit
de l'association vaincre la
mucoviscidose
des animations sont notamment prévus à
saint germain en laye 25 premiers
comités locaux au tour de karl olive une
quinzaine de maires et d'élus évinois
soutiennent emmanuel macron leur
objectif être source de propositions
pour le programme de l'actuel président
de la république et fédérer les soutiens
sur le terrain
[Musique]
et vous entendiez la tenue de ce procès
à versailles avec les incendiaires du
chapiteau de chanteloup les vignes qui
comparaissait devant la justice le
verdict est tombé trois personnes parmi
les mises en cause dans cette affaire
ont été condamnés à cinq ans de prison
dont trois avec sursis une quatrième
personne a été relaxé pour un incendie
mais reconnus coupables de violences
urbaines trois ans de prison dont deux
avec sursis tous sont interdits de se
rendre à chanteloup-les-vignes pendant
une durée de quatre ans les faits
remonte dans la nuit du 2 au 3 novembre
2019 ou le chapiteau de chanteloup les
vignes étaient détruits par les flammes
l'actualité de cette semaine jean michel
fourgous aussi une actualité politique
avec cette échéance présidentielle qui
se rapproche des premiers débats qu'on a
pu voir éclore sur sur les médias cette
semaine et votre famille les
républicains doivent se choisir aussi un
candidat il ya un congrès numérique est
organisée ce samedi pour déterminer le
mode de désignation de ce candidat il ya
deux pistes pour le moment qui sont
évoqués cette primaire que des candidats
veulent ou la désignation d'un candidat
lors d'un congrès pour quelle solution
penchez vous est-ce que la solution de
la primaire est la plus adaptée selon
vous moi je pense que oui la primaire
bon et fait ses preuves dans l'histoire
des démocraties et pas que la france est
un bon bon alors il faut qu'elle soit la
plus ouverte possible je pense m'enfin
même temps faut pas que sortir de deux
les cartes il peut y aller quand même
dans dans chaque courant politique il ya
quand même voilà quelque chose de
cohérent pour la france
d'intelligent de gens qui ont une
culture économique puisque aujourd'hui
un courant politique qui vous parle avec
des grandes idées philosophiques c'est
bien mais sinon ils n'ont pas de vision
économique n'ont pas de vision
scientifique ils ont pas envoyé de 2,2
le monde de demain c'est sa demande des
savoir-faire nouveau donc en quoi bon
j'ai absolument non dans mon courant
républicain va ya il ya quand même un
maximum de gens responsables qui ont une
expérience un peu des responsabilités du
facteur humain des problèmes économiques
sociaux moi c'est ça qui me dont il faut
quand même rester dans cette cohérence
et un juste milieu à trouver faut que ça
sedan l'écart type comme on dit mais
faut pas non plus que ce soit trop
réduit il faut pas non plus que ce soit
ouvert à tous les aventuriers de service
attendue car on a compris locaux la mer
et sérieux verte la france ses salariés
on veut des gens sérieux avaient choisi
moi je suis je soutiens et mme pécresse
est pas où ces mots je très transparent
je suis une fille sérieuse un parcours
irrégulier est là dans frais dans ses
études dans ses expériences
professionnelles dans la compréhension
du monde
un peu de l'interné seul c'est pour être
dans la république vous quand même une
vision vision qui sort au delà de votre
votre quartier un bon mais qui a déterré
donc sa candidature pour cette élection
présidentielle à elle a eu en plus des
personnalités ministériel comme
importante là elle a modifié les
périmètres des universités si
aujourd'hui on à paris saclay qui a été
numéro un mondial au classement de
shanghai en mathématiques je pense
qu'aulas est là elle a aussi modifié le
crédit impôt recherche qui a sauvé je
pense les cerveaux français qui sont
restés moi c'est démesuré concret c'est
pas du baratin c'est pas du jeu à
manipulation
voilà qu'en ait des gens qui qui ont qui
ont vraiment apporter une vraie valeur
ajoutée au pays ça mais quand vous
regardez les candidatures ont enfin la
voilà la raison pour laquelle je
soutiens donc valérie pécresse
maintenant il parlait des autres
candidats oui on peut citer xavier
bertrand eric ciotti michel barnier
aussi philippe juvin merci jean michel
fourgous et d'avoir été avec nous et je
le rappelle président de saint quentin
en yvelines et maire également de la
commune d'el en cours comme chaque
semaine à présent votre rubrique légal
chez king pour vérifier ce que disent
les acteurs de l'actualité vincent
couronne du collectif des surligneurs
est décrypte aujourd'hui une proposition
de jean luc mélenchon candidat à la
prochaine élection présidentielle avec
la france insoumise
jean luc mélenchon pas en guerre contre
la vie chère il propose ainsi une fois
élu de bloquer immédiatement les prix
des biens de première nécessité gaz
électricité et alimentation pour
justifier sa demande jean luc mélenchon
compare avec la situation des gels hydro
alcooliques et des masques dont les prix
avaient été plafonné pendant la crise
sanitaire sauf que ce qui était permis
pour les gels et les masques pendant la
crise ne l'est pas pour les biens de
première nécessité commençons par le
principe dans notre droit les prix sont
librement fixés c'est ce que prévoit la
constitution vise aussi le droit de
l'union européenne conséquence la
détermination des prix doit résulter de
la rencontre de l'offre et de la demande
et ne peut pas en principe être
déterminée par l'état cette règle vaut
donc pour le gaz et pour l'électricité
saufs précise une directive européenne
pour les personnes dans le besoin qui
peuvent bénéficier d'une aide de l'état
mais alors pourquoi la france at-elle pu
bloquer et prix des masques et des gels
et bien parce que plusieurs textes
européens permettent à l'état
d'intervenir sur le marché pour
plafonner un prix dans des situations
d'urgence urgence qu'il n'ya pas pour
les produits de première nécessité dans
ces circonstances comment alors faire
face à l'augmentation des prix qui est
réel et poserait problème incertain eh
bien l'état peut tout à fait distribuer
des aides des aides directes 1 plutôt
que de plafonner les prix il le fait
déjà pour le gaz et l'électricité avec
par exemple un chèque énergie on
pourrait très bien imaginer pour
l'alimentation la même chose lutter
contre les inégalités est toujours
possible il suffit de savoir quel chemin
emprunter mais c'est vrai que pour un
candidat jetée d'une tribune 1 je
bloquerai les prix est bien plus vendeur
que de promettre à tiquer alimentaire
pour les plus démunis
le retour à présent tant attendu de
bixente mais rien senti steban pour la
partie loisirs dans cette émission et
bixente à croissy sur seine on pourra
savourer un voyage entre le réel et
l'imaginaire une partie du château chat
noria a été aménagé pour accueillir
l'exposition légaux architecture imaginé
par la commune de croatie epicure studio
et histoire en briques cinq salles ont
été investis pour découvrir l'univers
lego en famille et pour vous faire la
visite nous avons fait appel un petit
sorcier que vous connaissez bien
regarder
[Musique]
vous aurez peut-être la chance de
croiser un petit personnage bien
familier en visitant l'exposition légaux
architecture du château chan aurier à
croissy-sur-seine à les tâches d'abord
avec un petit saut entre l'imaginaire
légaux et la pop culture elle a beaucoup
aimé cette salle avec le côté coloré
qu'on avait beaucoup moins en bas et
puis ben l'imaginaire qui est dedans
aussi enfin surtout dans dans un monde
où mon rêve beaucoup
où il ya plein de petites scènes de vie
mais harry peut aussi se cacher du côté
du réel avec deux salles une dédiée à la
france et ses monuments et une deuxième
pièce à côté vous allez faire un tour du
monde donc en passant par sydney dubaï
vous allez passer par l'egypte etc et
puis dans la salle dite noire alors là
je vais pas tout vous dévoiler vous
allez avoir la salle harry potter mais
il faut rester dans la surprise pour
harry potter parce qu'en fait vous avez
le château d'harry potter il ya
tellement de choses à voir dedans avec
sa cinquantaine d'oeuvres cette balade
nostalgique au pays de la construction
n'a qu'un seul objectif mêler les
générations justement donc les plus
adultes entre guillemets vont se régaler
avec l' architecture et les enfants vont
se régaler avec l'architecturé avec leur
monde a eu pour votre visite harry
devrait bien être du côté de poudlard
mais qui sait peut-être préférera-t-il
vous attendre à un autre endroit
nous ait eu la chance de rencontrer
harry potter du cnt sur place en
personne exactement alors l'événement de
ce week-end c'est aussi la première
édition du chapiteau concert festival
oui organisait à tremblay sur mauldre
chapiteaux seront dressées pour
accueillir des artistes aux univers très
variés le festival commence dès ce soir
à 18h30 et on a avec nous l'une des
têtes d'affiché greg zlap bonsoir
bonsoir donc merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur ce plateau grecque cela
vous êtes harmoniciste et chanteur je
n'aurai pas le temps de donner toute
votre carrière dans son cou mais six
albums vous êtes fait connaître
notamment grâce aux soirées grec tam à
l'utopia à paris vous avez accompagné de
nouveaux artistes
de la chanson française en studio comme
florent pagny ou johnny hallyday et
notamment en accompagnant ce dernier sur
scène à partir de 2009 en mettant le feu
à ses concerts par des solos endiablés
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
participer à cette première édition du
festival puisque c'est le côté
éclectique peut-être parce que je trouve
ça le fait qu'il y ait encore des gens
assez fou pour monter un nouveau
festival après tout la période qu'on a
vécu n'était distancié y avait les
pattes concerne je trouve ça génial donc
je soutiens à fond cette initiative et
oui c'est tout redémarre maintenant donc
la tournée redémarre et je suis
impatient de retrouver le public vous
allez jouer votre album rock est sorti
en 2020 notamment votre sixième album
comme je disais c'est un album avec de
nombreuses collaborations comme un duo
avec m
ami kane ou encore manu codjia mais
aussi des solos d'harmonica quel message
avez vous lu voulu transmettre dans
cette production a en fait le pour moi
la musique n'a de sens que si elle est
partagée donc pour moi l'essentiel c'est
au rendez-vous en live toujours et
la dominer les rock ce qu'on verra sur
scène c'est rock mais surtout on dit
jamais je vais aller écouter un concert
quand on vote c'est vrai on va voir un
concert donc en fait c'est un show que
qu'on va voir mais je suis très attaché
à sa c'est à dire il faut sur scène il
faut se donner à 200% et
il faut que les gens repartent avec les
étoiles plein les yeux et justement
c'est un homme qui se dit rock mais
votre passé c'est aussi la sole le blues
c'est un peu de jazz vous avez souhaité
mêler ces genres dans l'album rock it
alors ce qui est ce qui est rigolo c'est
que tout le monde quand on dit harmonica
tout le monde pense savoir ce que c'est
en général les gens concert dédié au
western
[Musique]
ou alors le blues voilà l'harmonica
c'est bien puisque ça c'est un
instrument qui qui a sa place dans
toutes les musiques c'est ce que j'aime
moins en fait c'est de placer
l'harmonica dans des contextes où on le
connaît pas et notamment c'est ce qui
s'est passé avec avec johnny puisque
dans ces shows énorme de johnny on
imaginait très bien des guitares
rock des guitares le stade
qui aurait pensé à l'harmonica et bien
johnny c'était c'était quelqu'un qui
avait suffisamment d'audace pour laisser
la place
un instrument aussi ridicule que
l'harmonica et c'était explosif vous
n'avez pas justement dix ans aux côtés
de johnny hallyday on retrouve parmi les
solos de votre album gabriel ou encore
le blues du pénitencier on peut
d'ailleurs écouter un petit extrait
[Musique]
ah ah
à
[Musique]
[Rires]
ah ah
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour connaître la suite rendez vous ce
samedi soir au tremblay sur mauldre une
dernière question peut être échangé cet
album finalement c'est un hommage vous
avez dit avec johnny hallyday c'est ça
il ya une partie dommage avec john alité
gérant toujours hommage à johnny sur
scène
on sort pas indemne de dix ans de
tourner avec johnnie j'ai appris
énormément cette époque il y avait
tellement d'humanité le monde et
générosité que je porte en moi en fait
cette vision de la scène qui est qui
était la sienne et donc à chacun de mes
concerts je lui rende hommage on jouait
le blues du pénitencier de ce qu'on a vu
et puis ce solo de gabriel que je viens
de vous interprétez
je rappelle vous serez présent demain à
21h au premier festival chapiteau
concert de trembler sur maul la première
édition du festival donc avec un casting
de gala puisque dès ce soir on
retrouvera rover à 21h demain juste
avant vous c'est christelle adam sender
authentique pour de la musique
l'ambiance sol et dimanche une journée
consacrée au reggae biga ranx à 15h et
danakil à 18 heures pour retrouver
toutes les informations mais aussi pour
acheter vos tickets rendez vous sur le
site internet de l'événement qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran alors de la
musique toujours bixente électro cette
fois-ci direction versailles oui avec
les nocturnes électro c'est l'occasion
de flâner dans l'ain pendant la nuit
parmi les bosquets les fontaines du
jardin du jardin du château de
versailles c'est samedi 25 septembre à
20h30 chaque lieu sera mise en lumière
sur les bandes son de dj français comme
ed banger 'juste justice clara 3000 et
d'autres encore si vous n'avez pas la
chance de voir greg zlap en concert donc
c'est aussi une très bonne façon de
passer son samedi soir en musique alors
comme chaque semaine on fait découvrir
les événements pour le week-end à venir
mais aussi pour celui d'après week-end
des 2 et 3 octobre avec cette semaine
un voyage en orient c'est ça vous allait
nous emmener en orient oui comme vous le
dites cette semaine un voyage nous
partons en voyage avec l'événement un
fabuleux voyage en orient c'est
l'interview express
[Musique]
je suis nadia meliani l'événement auquel
je vous convie à un voyage fabuleux en
orient qui aura lieu les 2 et 3 octobre
sur la commune du perray-en-yvelines
en un week end vous allez pouvoir
comment dire voyager en orient alors on
va commencer par une conférence à 15h30
autour de la calligraphie et de
l'histoire de l'écriture arabe on aura
accès également à un compteur qui est
mandaté par l'institut du monde arabe
qui sera là pour nous conter une
histoire des mille et une nuits
[Musique]
à 19h30 le restaurant sera ouvert on
servira alors un méchoui et un couscous
traditionnel
pendant qu'un groupe de musiciens jouera
des musiques
orientales mais aussi des musiques
chantées par des occidentaux mais qui
sont très imprégné par la culture la
culture arabe le temps que la danseuse
se prépare et qu'elle nous fasse trois
passages très très sympa vous pourrez
aussi danser avec elle
[Musique]
et on poursuit notre déroulé de cet
agent dan autres déroulé avec un
festival de théâtre c'est à bougival
michel c'était une édition particulière
puisque c'est la 30e édition le 30e
festival de théâtre de bougival revient
en force pendant deux semaines une pièce
sera jouée chaque soir du jeudi au
dimanche
ça fait huit ans tout ça commence dès
jeudi prochain avec parce que moi aussi
je suis un être humain on va s'attarder
également quelques secondes sur la
programmation du week-end le samedi
insoumise à camille claudel à 20h45 un
hommage à l'artiste sculpteur qui se
définissait elle-même ainsi le dimanche
à 16 heures ce sera ring la bague en
anglais donc une pièce comme son nom
l'indiqué tourner autour des relations
entre hommes et femmes à travers l'image
de plusieurs couples le tarif sera de 11
euros si vous souhaitez voir une seule
pièce et 40 euros pour l'accès aux huit
spectacles avec o'shea maintenant si
vous êtes plutôt d'humeur extérieur une
sortie entre la cime des arbres et un
petit peu de poésie maintenant c'est ça
avec les rencontres de l'arbre à la
celle-saint-cloud pendant deux jours ce
sera l'occasion d'échanger autour des
thèmes la santé des arbres et la santé
par les arbres au programme un débat
entre une experte en arboriculture
urbaine une architecte paysagiste ou
encore une sylviculture et parmi les
temps forts également un salon du livre
avec la présence pour dédicacer échanges
d'amélie nothomb écrivaine ghilane
golfier journaliste et auteur spécialisé
en jardinage ou encore yves duteil
parrain de l'événement et président
d'une association pour le reboisement
des espaces sinistrés toutes les
informations donc sur le site de la
celle saint cloud on termine avec du
sport et je sais que ça vous fait
plaisir bixente du côté de mantes la
jolie c'est ça la petite touche sportive
du week-end avec l'as mantaise qui
organisera les championnats de france de
dragon boat un sport insolite semblables
entre le canoë et la pirogue la
particularité on y monte à 22 donc 20
pagayeurs un batteur pour la cadence et
un barreur afin de garder la ligne de
course grégory si vous voulez y aller
prévoir prévoyez donc un véritable
équipage un message bien entendu
possible de juste regarder avec cette
activité cette vision insolite à voir du
côté de mantes-la-jolie merci bixente
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission se
retrouve bien sûr vendredi prochain pour
de nouvelles idées de sorties loisirs le
journal de la rédaction revient lui
lundi à l'antenne et d'ici là passez un
excellent week-end sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]